let's start with the with Lily Lily in
between Downton Abbey and with
Cinderella
now this you've done a lot of period
pieces milady
ah what up but that has to be not too
easy to fight off the undead in a
fortune like how does that exactly
actually it kind of helps somehow and in
question fittings we sort of kicked
rules and lunged to make sure that were
able to do it well what sort of what
sort of Elizabeth are we going to me
here because one of the biggest
differences between the original book
and sets reimagining is what size the
zombies there's that but this is
obviously but she's you know she's uh
you know his light-hearted she's a you
know she's not as easy not taking
offenses easily the original and we'll
see she's much more badass but away this
so what serve Elizabeth we're going to
see on screen um a fierce one she's and
I feel like within the relationship
having Darcy all that sort of inner
conflict and all that sexual frustration
and longing kind of comes out in an
decapitating zombies and then and she's
really good at being us five girls the
Bennet sisters at fighting together in
destroying together was really really
funny I want to go to Jack because I
noticed that we didn't see a lot of mr.
Wickham in that clip which at the
reporter in me immediately thinks is
that are some sort of twist is there
something you guys are trying to obscure
her hide here or what can you tell me
I think Wickham so shrouded in mystery
it's um it stays very true to the novel
which you know but at the same time
there are a lot of new twists I mean two
identically going to us you don't pour a
master we're happy face turning you know
okay get my speech
alright Sam what about you because know
much how much of a jerk is Darcy here
we're going to be the first thing how do
you calibrate it - how did you calibrate
the jerkiness because you have to be
broom out in a way that is going to
initially turn off Elizabeth a little
bit and maybe the audience a little bit
at first as well but also you know still
make an intriguing and redeemable what's
the question how do I have enough money
sir yeah how jerky did you do make a
mere deposit um well he's just
misunderstood this may be race is knob
and very proud obviously but I haven't
seen it yet somehow we got too much
emotion what to wait to find out I guess
Bella obviously you get to fight zombies
and that's pretty awesome and something
the most been fun to film what's up you
get three trainee or anything to for
these action scenes or what I just read
it no I get my training I did about four
months of coming through it was great
it's like his channel mind's eye
that and then we did about a month when
I came out with all the sisters we did
more martial arts photography weapons
also sleep that's great sounds fun
Douglas you guys are in this bizarre
situation of playing these like
well-known characters but there will
encourage some classical literature but
your played versions have already
previously adapted characters so do you
go back and look at any of that very
source materials we just sort of throw
it all out
I don't think previously filmed
adaptations necessarily useful although
I have seen a lot of them but for me it
was about going back to the original
book just just kind of figuring out
instead of knowing who I wanted to be
before I arrived on set and then just
like my interactions with the other
actors in the scene staged a create we I
think I get to hang on on the guys have
gone before you on it do your thing I
think a little bit of yourself balanced
well in that you obviously have some
experience with passionate fan bases
with Doctor Who
but I mean Jane Austen fans are pretty
passionate to in their own right not my
friends did you have friends and family
like when you when you got this role
that rocks saying you're in Pride and
Prejudice and you had to explain that
this version was just like a wee bit
different from what they might be
thinking well the clue is in the title
hole really probably prejudices all
these know yeah I think I think it's a
really fun film and I think I think it's
a sort of film that you could take your
chick to there's a great central love
story in it
people's people's heads to internal some
of these rigs exactly what Pride and
Prejudice needed I think remaining woo
BRR were there any sequences from Seth's
book and you were particularly excited
to sort of translate to feel like when
you poured through the focus that I
cannot wait the first battle scene with
the sisters in the ballroom getting a
stage of that and getting to reveal who
they were whether they thought that was
fun well instead weathering African
Senor book once you guys' Domingo
feature film and you were sort of really
excited to see how that was going to
look and you know bring your words to
life and Jonathan I know this sounds
like a cop-out but I was just excited
that it was finally getting made we have
some false starts along the way but but
you know I have to say overall I having
just seen a rough cut of the film
recently I think the thing that I'm the
most excited about is that Burke clearly
understands the tone of this absolutely
stupid ridiculous idea and that the only
way to really go at it is to do it
without ever winking once at the
audience you know
I was we were talking backstage a little
bit every one of these actors to a
person really in this and every one of
them is acting as earnestly as if they
were in you know just sort of Pride and
Prejudice movie and I think that's why
it works is because the movie isn't you
know going for the joke it isn't it is
winking at you explain the most straight
Pride and Prejudice beautifully shot
elegantly costume wonderfully made and
acted and then zombie show up and you're
like what the [ __ ] is going on so the
threat feels real the threat is not
playful abs yeah there's this the odd
notes play for real and you're invested
in the confidence in this all right I
want to know from all the we'll start
off feeling a deadline what would be
your personal favorite weapon for
fighting the sorry stricken it can be
something you use in the film or just
anything you would like to use to fight
off a horde of the undead it's lilium
sort of oh well the kind of thing was
that we had like Doc is getting an
absolutely everywhere I think has been
with Pattinson
so I take it doctor good shout I am a
samurai sword but some I probably rather
machine gun
they did exist muskets pretty useless
this one should fire dad then you have
to ask the zombies to wait a second but
the samurais was pretty cool Joseph a
childhood fantasy fulfilled well I never
got to do any fighting really
I just ate things so I faked a series of
poisonous zombie muffins and lure them
into my bakery and pretend that I'm
going to give them treats but actually
I'm going to poison them a massive I'm
in the air on a boat yeah we disagree on
their CEO should Brogan ravage your
baggage is your Inuyasha yeah to escape
just ninja and a select crew so
everyone's wrong when in our movie when
zombies if they when they first bite a
human you can't require a fake cover it
up you can't like tells they can live in
society for a little bit so is it kind
of in asking maybe there's a little bit
sense of paranoia what she saw in the
clip at the beginning in Dustin's too
passive thing kind of come from anyway
so maybe something good like with that
like assassin creed has nothing shoots
from here
no maybe that are machine gun our mom is
fine deeply Longboat whatever you went
still for a second then you just went in
complete opposite old life firmly to
kill Tom instead of new super yeah damn
I don't think a nuclear bomb option is a
good one I don't think that's gonna
Blackwater I don't know not in the late
17th century
yeah right yeah yeah guys are all
forgetting that the most dangerous
weapon is the heart of a warrior [ __ ]
again particularly the female warriors
in this film who were trained at Shaolin
and not Giotto which is [ __ ] yeah
yeah the Bennet sisters are the
deadliest and weapons
sisterhood well let me ask you guys this
who among you up here would be the first
to go in a real zombie economist who's
getting eaten first
we'd be neck today what about among the
cast who's getting eaten first
Tom we can't leave doc someone's going
to go I should probably go really I may
not know issues I'd say my me do someone
that's not hearing I'm taking the game
take one for the team
yep all right turn up all right look I
know you guys want to ask these guys a
lot of questions and so let's get to
that
on right there look at the spotlight is
the handy two questions for the cast and
the director and writer of Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies now is the time
and will story there with Wonder Woman I
was going by like a fantastic movie and
this is really great for Matt Smith my
daughter cutting of Indians remember one
fan she was too scared to ask you this
question do you ago I see yourself like
in similarities to the character you
play in this movie do i yes question
well because he keeps getting rejected
terribly good success with the ladies
though so no not really
please like kind I likes muffins so I
like to think that I'm quite kind and I
do like muffins what's not to like
alright hey how's it going Matt Swift
yeah how's me
transition them between filming TV like
dr. new and transitioning to filming it
could be like trying to refresh 20
points on this kind of major not really
difference well you know what it's all
it's just a camera there and lots of
nice actors and I've been having very
fortunate to work with Brewers people
that is gathered here so it's been it's
been rather nice but I miss making dr.
new because it's fun thanks a lot
you know it's not as going I have a
question for everyone how does your
character in the movie differ from the
original one in the book which 12 the
rich in the original progress okay so
I'm not sorry Lily wasn't want to start
with you ah fear sir I mean this planet
is already an incredibly independent
free thinking strong young woman but I
think it's enhanced even find this and
she is
take that keep going down money wells
um well what's uh what was so great
about the script and about sense focus
you don't normally changing the
characters over marketing you know still
mr. Darcy with his prejudices is
snobbery but with a samurai sword and
martial arts techniques but essentially
it it's private branches but with a
zombie plague apocalypse the people are
still trying to keep up appearances now
the the snobbery that still they make in
English societies still there but too
small but when I wrote the book what I
was trying to do is pretty simple
mistake you're not going to improve a
Jane Austen especially not me so my
intent was take all her characters take
all the themes and just turn them up to
at 11:00 and so the intention was you
know Lizzy is strong in the book and and
now she's like like Lily says she's a
badass it's just it's for everyone I
think it's taking those character traits
that are in the original novel and just
playing them to a slightly ridiculous
levels what thank you very much
questions Oh the other question guys the
question line is right over there to the
right while we're waiting for the people
lined up Matt want to continue honest
with your character how you decide to
sort of adapt mr. Collins you take any
other other inspirations oh yeah I won't
actually do the first me and God have it
but I was like it'd be cool to do it if
he if he was in love with Darcy so you
see if you can see them flame and I what
I loved about the script that it was all
the beats from Pride and Prejudice all
those characters stood up they were the
same they really were invested in them
it was just saying most of them saying
that dropping of zombie apocalypse how
would they how would mrs. Bennet try and
marry off all the daughters while this
was going on and how would Darcy try and
live the way he lived how would that
happen
and yeah the result it's exciting and
fun Ian
well Burton said how did you guys talk
about who already have a book that's you
know reimagining of another book now I
bring to the screen how did you talk
about changes from your book set I just
I just honestly birth came in with the
vision of the movie and clearly
understood what the intention was with a
book and God you know like I said before
the humor
never be forced or jokey just be
straight frankly you know I'm just here
as an author I didn't have anything into
the film it's it's burr and stick Caston
and and so I just completely trusted
these lovely people and I'm very happy I
did we have a question right out there
now they have got actually just stole my
question we're going to source materials
how you do that so we'll go with memory
moments while filming for the entire
pass okay when we go y'all some
strategies Douglas oh I think I was very
fortunate with Matt before and I've
known you for a while and so for me it's
just the whole experience is so much fun
and if you can tell on that we just
having the best times our lives
yeah I think lily has quite a good one
quite we just forget about which is so
good it'll be anything I have to say
this Jonah sort of an extra sort of
zombie extra longing floor you are it's
a bizarre me when you when you stamp on
an extras head I thought it was a dummy
but it was a
pretty hard and it was a rehearse and it
wasn't even a real tank and but he was
fine character same time too didn't move
oh yeah yes for your number he was fine
and it was a hazard because everywhere
you look there were these zombies
dripping in blood and fake ones real
ones and I got off this horse really
Guardian and chato a poor man's head
cousin they gave them a little extra
money it's going method okay very good
hey we're thinking about zombies but we
also have a period piece so for the
actors how did you prepare your
characters to bring those together just
a question how do you just get I mean
that's one thing you have to get in tune
we get a period piece and Lily
absolutely talked about you've been
doing different periods all you have in
one aspect rather how do you have to get
in the framework at that time period and
they are sort of our classes and the
timing stuff
Matt well I mean I think I think that's
the challenge of a film like this is to
totally understand those two things and
make them work together alone you know
as an actor you sort of turn up you get
into costume for you weirdly enough
could be future could be the past until
the same the end it but yeah but I do
think Tony trying to try to balance
those two ideas zombies and period
deserve it's you know what's going to
make film interesting I actually think
that in history there were used to be
some massive plagues the Black Plague at
least be lots of back then there was
more common for sort of things not like
this but no I don't see zombies or a
zombie movie necessarily in science
fiction yeah something could happen when
this terrible illness is going on around
the world and you know if a disease
develops into a certain way where people
start biting each other and infect each
other that way I mean yeah so actually I
didn't have to like separate the history
of it from that actually think it almost
made it easier they were you deal with
more uses this sort of plate that thanks
hey it's really per said now that you've
seen this film come to fruition are you
planning on taking any more step further
any more films sure I mean I'm not sure
well we'll see I mean you know the cold
light of day answer is we'll see how it
does and you know people are excited
about another one but no I wouldn't be
opposed to it at all and can I just say
something just to take a minute because
I'll probably never get a chance to sit
here in the fall age again the fact that
we are here in front of so many people
in Hall H Lord I used to stand in line
for hours to get into this hall for
years
and the fact the fact that a movie
called Pride and Prejudice and Zombies
that had probably a tenth of the budget
of the movies that you guys have been
watching all day in the world work and I
love superhero movies too and I'm a fan
but the fact that this movie is up here
is it just it's a testament to the
people that have found the book and love
the book promoted the book and the
people who believed in the book and made
the movie I just want to thank everybody
because it's it's surreal to be here and
it's it's amazing so thank you for yes
miss I'm not such a big thin and pretty
cast you guys are all wonderful my
question is first step in the book it's
left up to the imagine to the reader's
imagination to what happens to mr.
Collins and Charlotte Lucas well we get
a visual estupido what is to come
without giving too much away I will say
that that is one of the small
differences and I think you know just
know that the people who deserve their
comeuppance in the movie probably get it
but perhaps in different ways so you
know for instance there was also I think
it's been a while since I read the book
but I also like had someone becoming a
continent at the end that was maybe a
step too far so I think that they
improved the book in very material ways
by not playing to some of my baser
stupider here ooh thanks a lot hello sup
Sharla my question is
for anyone who wants to answer what's a
favorite classic story of yours that you
would like to see get the primer Edison
zombies treatment may be Cinderella
oh yes got that song anyone want a
picture sir
I've been thinking about resonate who
hunts vampires I don't think that movie
would work out so well
oh stop I was being like that if I if I
could come up with something as quick on
the spot like this I'd probably be in
the ocean shoes and making less money
right you know I mean what's fun is like
I can walk into bookstores one of my
favorite things to do and there's always
you know George Washington werewolf
hunter and and watering frights and you
know I mean there's there's no [ __ ] I -
oh yeah feel free take any of these but
but no I mean I think to me the thing
that was so specific about and by the
way the idea initially the tackle Prada
prejudice came from my editor for books
Jason Kula yay Jason uh but it just and
we've talked about this too and I think
the cast can speak to this it's just so
weird how seamless it was when you just
decided to add the zombie apocalypse to
product prejudice it was like it was
written with something missing
not that Jane Austen got me wrong I'm
just saying that like in this one case
haven't found any other classic book
that really you know was that
inspiration that seemed that seems yeah
I mean one of the key things to this is
in Pride and Prejudice you have the
Napoleonic Wars going on but never
explained you just don't have all these
handsome soldiers riding through and as
an American we have no idea what's going
on so to take out the Napoleonic Wars
and throw in the zombie pandemic there
was absolutely structurally a place with
it okay thank you remarkably like Ben by
the way it's good luck man it's good
luck strong hey what's up I had a
question for the author what do you
think if Jane Austen read your book what
would her reaction I've got this
question and first of all I would say
when I wrote the book I was there were
no expectations that anyone read it so
we were all caught off guard that became
a success but but then once it became a
success I was happy but I was also
terrified because the Jay Knights are
legion and they are you know wonderful
devoted fans and I thought that they
were going to burn me in effigy however
I will say that I've been very
pleasantly surprised that they are
extraordinary
they all have extraordinary senses of
humor and the people who love this book
most crowded Prejudice and Zombies tend
to be the ones who love Jane Austen love
pride prejudice because as it turns out
Jane Austen herself wrote some you know
some sort of early gothic fiction she
was interested in the cop and she was
really really funny I mean Jane Austen
is an extraordinarily funny author and
so while we would never know I like to
think
she would take it you know all good
strike that or you know guilty I'm not
sure one of the two and that's done
you're steppin her head probably she was
done all right that's going to do it for
pride persons on these guys Johnny Mac
Sam I love James Ryan brothers amis Otis
benefit 2016
you